want to kick your fourth of july party
up a notch kiwi johnson joins us with
some great decor and party ideas welcome
hi
thanks for letting me have created this
amazing amazing table
and i am in shock over how much it costs
this whole table how much
under 25 dollars how did you do that
the secret is to shop at like your 98
cent stores like in walmart and 98 cents
or your dollar trees and you just
utilize the things that's already in
your house and what are the best ways to
serve our guests for fourth of july
fourth of july so for fourth of july i
was focusing on the table so what the
idea is to make a full table make sure
you have your candles your flower and a
focal point like um just for me it was
just this brass
center piece here grass centerpiece i
was going to decorate them with um
bows but we ran out of time oh well
that's okay this looks great and you're
gonna actually teach us how to make a
really cool focal point with stuff we
already may have in our refrigerator
right in our refrigerator explain let's
let's see how we do this i love that so
what you guys will need to make this
it's called a flower um a fruit flower
base is you're gonna have to have a big
base okay and then we already pre
let me see we already pre
floured the small base oh okay okay so
you got a little baby one right so we
already pre-floured it what you're gonna
do is stick it right in the middle oh
okay
pretty and then what you do is you take
your fruits and you stuff them in
between oh my god you stuff them in
between and that helps to put a little
umph inside of your flower vases it
gives it a little extra pop and you know
what typically typically is easier to do
without the flowers you want to do this
part without the flowers first but
because again the time that we have i
already pre-flowered for you guys oh my
goodness yes it looks so cute i love
this idea where you you're using all
this fresh stuff and maybe you you know
you've made your little cake with the
the blueberry and the strawberry flag on
it and you have something yes if you
guys have extra fruit just put them
inside your flower base it makes for
extra um for that fourth of july party
uh no you said you got a lot of this at
the dollar store i did show me some of
the specific items that we can get there
for
under a dollar you can get your candles
this candle here all these tin foil
um centerpieces you get there these
flags what are these vases here these
basically everything this
these stars everything you kind of
decorate the table with i utilize the
dollar store so that
and this is something i already had i
love i love using these as your drink
glasses and just throwing in a festive
straw that is so cute if people want
more party planning ideas where can they
find you the partypantry.net or on
instagram the party pantry las vegas and
you can make this beautiful centerpiece
and eat it after you're done
yes you can start snacking on these
little blueberries and stuff yes i love
it thank you so much thank you guys for
having me we'll be right back
so cute